I'm Lila Manheim from Dancing with the
Stars Hey oh it makes sure you catch
Disney night Monday
what time Oh God
et crashing my low Mannheim and Whitney
Carson's Dancing with the Stars
rehearsal and getting all the deets on
their incredible themed routine
I mean I'm sweating right now yes it's
finished take this break and it's hard
that's all your quick step is very
technical yeah lots of posture lots of
frame so it's been a little bit
difficult but we're getting there you
guys got a 29 out of 30 this past week
what are you gonna bring to this dance
to get that perfect score on Disney
night gosh we're gonna really try and
please one because he is the hardest on
us so we're gonna get him good frame
good technique I think that's really
what he's looking for
it's gonna be hard to because he's all
about that classic style of dance and
it's Disney week so it's very flashy and
I don't know if he's gonna buy that but
I'm gonna just try to make up for it
with a really great are you worried
about a possible double elimination on
Monday wasn't it just said I actually
don't know is there will be look I was
calculating it in my mind you know how
it usually it's top three if we're going
at the same rate that we're at top four
so the problem will be up oh my gosh you
write on Disney night that's so sad if
there's rumors about it it's probably
happening yeah let's just get ready for
it but the pair is putting in work and
even took a trip to Disneyland to get
inspired and to celebrate Whitney's 25th
birthday I have to say happy belated
birthday Disney leader day did you get
any inspiration from Mickey that's why
we were we've met
mr. incredible on Elastigirl they were
very nice they showed us how to pose can
you show us yeah so obviously the
classic yeah yeah oh you guys are yeah
how we are okay putting you in the hot
seat what did you get her for her
birthday
ah I got her who got me something good
one I got her for Lakers tickets and
like the box amazing rockets freaking
out my husband's even more I got her a
little necklace with a star on it you
can do Dancing with the Stars and she I
know I'm supposed to be the star in the
competition but she's my star that is
the most thoughtful thing ever
yes so good Portman award yeah you told
us that you felt like a third wheel
Riker and Milo so did you feel like a
third wheel and does not always with the
producer all day like the second I saw
the producer
I have a friend finally I do think that
we figured out your ballroom crush ah no
this is what happens when you start
spreading rumors wait maybe he's really
mad at me it's fine listen do you say it
no say it I'm sure that's the person she
was thinking is it Maddie Ziegler that's
exactly she trying to set that up with
definitely are you into it Maddie she's
a great girl but she's not gonna happen
it's just not gonna happen why if she is
super cool and I really do like her and
I hope to know her for a long time and
it's funny because she would have the
exact same response as I'm having right
now we would have to like to sit wait me
down and be like Whitney it's not gonna
happen I think I just love them both so
much though it's true that happen and we
couldn't double all the time that would
be fun that would be
right now though Milo's focused on
Maylene his dancing are you guys doing
any flips lifts
crazy jumps we aren't but we do have
something pretty special at the
beginning so no lifts or tricks but this
is kind of like a know what would you
call it
montre it's a special feature yes three
words to describe Mondays dance
incredible Oh
come on obviously it's back that I think
intense it's gonna be very like
jam-packed action yeah I want to say
nostalgic but like I don't
I also don't want to say that because
that's a lame last word it's gonna bring
back fields of Incredibles
[Music]
[Applause]